hello everybody how are you this is
Parks and recollection again yes and I
am one of your hosts Jim O'Hare better
known as Gary Larry Jerry Terry or Barry
uh and sitting well across I mean really
not next to me though you're always in
my heart like you're right with me is
hi I'm Greg
I feel like our voices are so different
like yours and mine yeah I feel I'm very
loud and obviously obnoxious and yours
is I can confirm both of us yeah I'm
sure you get you have every right to
yours is more adult oh my God yes I feel
yours I really appreciate you saying
that because I um I I recently turned
40. I have a child I have another child
on the way and real soon like real soon
yeah and yet I don't I still feel like a
little boy oh my gosh well but you know
what I I just turned uh
61. and I still feel like an idiot you
know like the age I don't know then I
look in the mirror and it's like what
the hell is going on oh sure you know
you see people on Facebook your friends
from high school and they're posting
you're like oh man they look like hell
and then you're thinking well they're
thinking the same thing about me yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's terrifying I um
recently uh I was having a lower back
stuff and I went to an orthopedist and
they're like all right well let's do a
scan or two and they did the MRI and I
came back in and he comes in he says you
know I have to tell you if I knew
nothing about you and I just saw this
image in front of me I would have
thought this was the back of like a 55
year old really and there's something
about a doctor saying yeah that's yeah
yeah that and he pretty much said to me
and I appreciate bluntness especially in
medicine yeah in medicine I think it's
it's needed you need to know the truth
about things and he said you have
coasted long enough on doing no exercise
it's time for you to actually step up
and I appreciated that
um I'm I'll do it soon enough yes yes
yes not today but soon enough soon
enough so you just turned 40 you're
saying that's right which brings me to
something I was going to mention I went
to a 40th birthday party and the fans
will be happy to hear this of our boy
Ozzy oh wow yes Aziz Ansari turned 40
and he had a birthday party and it was
super fun and many many levels
um uh as far as the cast goes our
fearless leader Amy was there uh Rashida
was there Retta was there Aziz showed up
which was nice that was nice yes then of
course the star of the night I was there
uh no but it was great um Mike Shore we
got to see Mike shore co-creator of this
show the reason we're even sitting here
today is because of someone like Mike
short so it was a wonderful night and it
turned out it was actually on the party
was on the exact date of Rashida's
birthday so aziz's wife had come out we
all stopped and sang Happy Birthday and
then Aziz goes but today is Rashida's
birthdays can do that yeah and then we
all sing Happy Birthday to Rashida but
anyway it was really what a great night
and of course you know Amy and Rasheed
and Retta and Aziz just anytime I'm
around that crowd it's just it's like
old times and you know when you put red
and I in a room it's like no time time
has passed oh yeah at all I mean red and
I are we were always tight you know uh
because we came into the show
both not knowing what was going to
happen neither one of us were series
regulars at first and so it was that
kind of thing but anyway I've taken
enough time we do have to talk about
this episode so it's a great no that's
that's awesome
and I think that the fans the thing that
people have to understand about Parks
and Rec you have to you have to and I'll
say it I've probably said it already and
I'll continue to say it it wasn't
when it came to everybody
getting along every you know um we had
Mike Shore handling the offices and all
of you guys and he doesn't play games
and we had Amy handling you know she was
our Queen and
um that's just how it was and so we're
still all like in love with each other
and
um anyway it was great to see them oh
great that's great that's great share my
little story no that's what you do
change your diaper good times my own
good time
no you're you're hobnobbing you're doing
you're playing like Aziz party bingo
like trying to cross off all the fun
people you see and I'm like what how
many diaper changes have I had done at
home that night so I'm glad you and I
are alive had equal nights different
lives